This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English, I'm Neil.
And I'm Georgina.
Covid-19 has changed everyday life for people in countries around the world.
But coronavirus wasn't the first pandemic to cause mass sickness and disrupt daily life.
Between 2002 and 2004, an outbreak of the disease known as SARS,
or severe acute respiratory syndrome, caused hundreds of deaths in southern China
before spreading to other parts of the world.
The virus that caused SARS survived by mutating,
changing as it reproduced itself in the bodies of infected people.
And this caused the virus to create strains, slight variations of the original.
Covid-19, the disease caused by the strain of the original SARS virus we are experiencing now,
has been called SARS-2.
In this programme, we'll be looking at the origins of Covid-19,
and hearing new evidence about the scale of the threat we face from the disease.
And of course, we'll be learning some new vocabulary as well.
But first, it's time for our quiz question.
We know that white blood cells make up part of the immune system our body needs to fight
infectious diseases like Covid-19, but how many white blood cells per microleiter does the
average adult human need? Is it A, 7000, B, 17000, or C, 70000?
Hmm, in that case, I'd say more is better, so C, 70,000.
Okay, we'll find out the answer at the end of the programme.
Now, Georgina, you mentioned that the disease spreading across the world today
wasn't the first Covid-19 type disease.
That's right. In fact, a recent research project in China has identified over 700 different types
of coronavirus carried by bats. Some of these virus strains are thought to have already crossed
over to humans. Dr Peter Dasack of New York's Eco Health Alliance
thinks that new strains of the virus have the potential to cause future pandemics.
He spent years in the Chinese countryside looking for the coronavirus that could jump from
bats to humans. Here he is talking to the BBC World Service Programme Science in Action.
It would have been great to have found the precursor to SARS-2, but what it would have been
even better is to have found it before SARS-2 emerged and raise the red flag on it and stop the
outbreak. But we didn't do that. What we were looking for were at the time, our hypothesis was that
SARS-1, the original SARS virus, which we all thought had disappeared, was still out there in bats
and that was what we were looking for. So we found a lot of SARS-1 related viruses.
Covid-19 may have been contained if scientists had known more about the disease as precursor.
That's a situation which existed before something and led to the development of that thing.
Here, the precursor of Covid-19 was the original SARS-1.
Any new cases of the virus would have been a red flag for another outbreak,
a symbol of danger that some action needs to be taken. Dr. Dasack believed that some form of SARS
remained in bats and based his investigations on this hypothesis, an idea which is suggested as a
possible explanation of something but which has not yet been proved correct. Another scientist
working to prevent new epidemics is the pathologist Professor Mary Falks.
The original SARS was treated as a respiratory disease which attacked the lungs.
But when working with infected patients, Professor Falks noticed that Covid-19 was damaging the
brain, blood and other organs as well. Clinicians have recognized that a lot of patients that have
Covid are exhibiting confusion, not necessarily aware of their environment appropriately,
some are having seizures. So there are some central nervous system abnormalities and as you know,
a lot of patients are exhibiting loss of sense of smell and that is a direct connection to the
brain as well. In some infected patients, coronavirus attacks the central nervous system,
the body's main system of nerve control consisting of the brain and spinal cord.
When severe, this can cause seizures, sudden violent attacks of an illness,
often affecting the heart or brain. It seems that Covid-19 type diseases are not going to
disappear anytime soon. Reminding us of the importance of the scientific research we've heard
about today. And the importance of boosting your immunity, which reminds me of today's quiz question.
You asked me how many white blood cells per microelita the human body has. I said C-70,000.
Well, if that was true, you've definitely boosted your immunity, Georgina,
because the correct answer is C, just 7,000. Today we've been discussing the strains or slight
variations of the virus, which causes Covid-19. Covid-19 has a previous disease called SARS as
its precursor, a situation which existed before something and caused the development of that thing.
Researchers used the idea that the virus had passed to humans from bats as their hypothesis.
Possible explanation for something which has not yet been proved true. By identifying new virus
strains, doctors hope unexplained cases can act as a red flag, a warning sign of danger to prevent
further outbreaks. Knowing about new strains is increasingly important as we find out more about
how coronavirus attacks the body's central nervous system, the brain and spinal cord,
which in some patients can cause seizures. Sudden violent attacks of an illness,
especially affecting the heart or brain. So try to stay safe, wash your hands and remember to
join us again soon. Bye for now. Bye!